sixty years ago today nine black
students entered an all-white high
school in Little Rock Arkansas the new
movie teaches all on earth the Little
Rock Nine it explores higher educational
inequality still plagues the United
States six decades later manacled riga
is here with the movie and it's
influential backer beyond a good morning
good morning education reforms still
such an important issue facing this
country the director of that film is
Sonya Loman her directorial debut caught
the eye in production backing of Emmy
award-winning filmmaker
Ava Devore named Ava lichens teach us
all to her critically acclaimed film
13th which highlights the racial
inequities of mass incarceration I sat
down with two filmmakers at the Langston
Hughes house in Harlem New York we're
one of the few countries in the world
that systematically and deliberately
spends less money to educate poor
children than a few children
it's not true that education is equal in
this country because there's still very
intense segregation happening in all
kinds of forms all over this country and
so what I loved about her film and what
she did that they get spoke to my film
13th in a way and that we're trying to
deconstruct the truths that are supposed
to be evident are actually falsehoods
are actually kind of veils pulled over
an ugliness that America hasn't dealt
with teach us all explores hyper
segregated schools around the country
where at least 75 percent of students
are of the same race millions and
millions of black and Latino kids will
go through a public education system
that does not educate them the film says
children living in poverty continue to
suffer my mom she makes about that
$9,000 a year it's five of us so you
could kind of like imagine you see in
these segregated schools is they tend to
get far fewer resources and very
importantly less experienced teachers
aside from parents everyone knows that
the teachers were the most influential
people in a child's life in their
development why do you think this
country isn't doing more to promote good
teachers to promote and give them better
raises if we were really serious about
social progress in this country teachers
would be paid like lawyers and doctors
and we would be not just sort of paying
lip service to teachers what we're
seeing is we're really seeing a
widespread disenfranchisement you have
children saying you know mr. Harnish
I have a quarter is that enough to buy a
book at the book fair and you just want
to cry and so you dig in your wallet and
you give them $10 because you want them
to have a book so ava is it more of a
race issue in this country
or is it an income inequality issue in
this country it's a mix of both I think
I mean definitely they go ahead in hand
I mean you know class in this country
has been conflated with race you know
with with Brown versus the Board of
Education race is protected it's a
loophole race has protected the class
was never protected you know that black
people and brown people were poor in
this country but you say that race
doesn't matter
you know there's still poor so you don't
have to serve that part of it you think
it's a given that a kid should go to
school and get an education wherever
they look it's not the environment that
a kid should be raised in this is not
like a pretty good safe environment what
is the solution I think just sort of
that idea again that we were you know a
lot of people said oh we're not racist
but on and now we're at a point where
it's not enough to say I'm not a racist
and you have to actually say I'm anti
racism and you need to take that stance
for me it's always going to come back to
the students and that's the connection
with the Little Rock Nine who were
teenagers when they took their stand and
they would show such unbelievable
courage such an important film in the
film teach us all is available on
Netflix today and you talk about hyper
segregated schools you know the average
family income is $15,000 at these
schools and public schools versus
$50,000 in the more integrated schools
so you do see the inequity and it starts
at such a young age and affects these
children here is a big difference and
that's why I think it's great that
they're pointing it out Ava Duvernay is
on a roll 1st 13th now this and now
she's working on Disney's wrinkle in
time I can't wait Sonia says she won the
lottery getting a back that down I think
she's right
thanks to be honest